foreign
[Music]
briefing for Thursday May 4th I'm Zoe
Thomas for The Wall Street Journal
Israel has for years been one of the
world's most vibrant hubs for Tech
startups but a combination of global
economic Trends and investors concerns
over a proposed judicial overhaul in the
country are making it hard for these
young companies to raise money in fact
in the first quarter of this year the
sector saw a 70 drop in fundraising
compared with the same time last year
according to IVC Research Center with me
to discuss the situation is our reporter
in Tel Aviv Dove Lieber Dove
internationally we've seen a pullback in
investing but how different is it for
the tech sector in Israel well we've
seen the same pressure or macroeconomic
pressure making challenges for
fundraising for Israeli startups here in
Israel like they're experiencing around
the world now most of that decline is
being attributed to the general
macroeconomic environment globally with
investors pulling back due to high
interest rates we do know that Israel
underperformed a global average in other
Tech hubs for raising money that those
Tech cups were also experiencing a
downturn but it was downturn it was a
little uh stronger and therefore that
suggests basically that there's also if
the political instability is playing a
role here and when you speak to
entrepreneurs uh here uh in Israel they
will tell you their own personal
experiences about dealing with investors
and some investors telling them to their
face that one of the reasons that
they're pulling back their investment or
they're holding off for now is because
of Israel's own political instability
that is connected to the judicial
overhaul Dove can you just remind us
about that judicial overhaul what's
going on and how is it specific
typically affecting the tech sector so
back in January uh brand new Israeli
government said that it was going to
overhaul the country's Judiciary
basically in a move that would weaken
the Supreme Court or weaken other
Justice Ministry officials and give more
power to lawmakers that proposal
launched one of the biggest protest
movements uh in the country's history
over a hundred thousand sometimes well
over a hundred thousand people protest
every week a large sector of the
protests included Israel's high-tech
Community okay which is something we
hadn't yet seen before in Israel the The
Tech Community getting very involved in
politics because many of them or the
vast majority of them believe that this
judicial overhaul is very bad for
business they say that it is scaring
away uh their investors because what
happens is the fear is that this
judicial overhaul could hand too much
power essentially to the government and
when that happens it's basically
facilitates corruption uh which is bad
for business is
quickly how important has Israel's text
sector been to the country's economy
isos Tech sector is the Beating Heart of
the country's economy it makes up about
16 percent of the GDP it's over 50
percent of exports for the country and
it makes up a huge part of tax revenue
for the country Israel especially for
the city of Tel Aviv so the success or
the lack of success for Israel's Tech
sector is plays a huge role in the
country's economy itself even
if you've came to some
going to do if this situation persists
there are a lot of Founders who say that
even though they don't want to leave
Israel that they may end up having to
leave Israel if the current situation of
this kind of political uncertainty
continues many have already decided to
incorporate new companies in the United
States rather than Israel if that allows
them a kind of getaway uh card if they
need to if if things deteriorate so much
in the country if there are capital
controls or other political issues
caused by the instability well they can
easily move their company or grow their
company in the United States if it's
already Incorporated there I'm curious
this industry might pull back or even up
and leave Israel given how important it
is to the overall economy of Israel
firstly for sure is it is a major
concern for for the government which is
a fairly right-wing government while the
tech industry is more associated with
the center left but at the same time
again the fact that it's the Beating
Heart of the economy the government
knows it can't allow uh Israeli
technology companies to to leave the
country at the same time the Israeli
technology industry has kind of created
a massive wealth crap in the country as
well so people who are connected to the
technology industry can make a decent
living but those who aren't connected to
the technology industry are basically
living in another world the country
itself is quite proud of the technology
industry it's a source of Pride for for
many Israelis it's a source of Pride for
prime minister Benjamin Netanyahu who
credits himself for changing Israel's
economy in such a way that produce or
facilitated the growth of this
technology industry uh you will find
people who support Israel around the
world constantly talking about the
miracle of Israeli technology so it is
it is part and parcel of the Israeli
identity this this Tech Nation if you
will so that would be a huge blow really
to the identity of the country not just
the economy of the country all right
that's our reporter Dove Lieber thanks
for joining us and that's it for today's
Tech news briefing for more Tech stories
head over to our website wsj.com I'm Zoe
Thomas for The Wall Street Journal
thanks for listening
foreign
[Music]